let's go next to our caller from the 906
area code 913
hey this is Anthony now here in
California I was recently reading a New
York Times you know
editorial or whatever and they were kind
of outlining the different paths that
would happen after the Moller
investigation you know like well if they
don't find anything in and they're if
you know this this etc right one of the
paths that they said would end in a
constitutional crisis where the
Republicans just refused to do anything
at all which actually kind of seems
likely at this point based on their
reaction to what happen happening can
you kind of outline what would happen in
that scenario well you mean the
logistics of it or what the consequences
would be well just more more along the
lines of well how would we actually get
any kind of justice what if Moeller does
go to Rod Rosenstein and says hey these
are the charges you know he you know
whatever collusion or whatever
money-laundering or you know campaign
finance whatever it is he broke the law
right and then the Republicans saying no
we're not gonna do anything
enough haven't yet that's why there's
there's one very simple solution to this
problem and that's called voting
five-and-a-half months from now that's
the solution because your concern is
exactly right you are completely correct
in asking this question and it is under
most scenarios extraordinarily likely
that nothing will happen even it because
remember the FBI special prosecutor
can't actually say that someone is
guilty of a crime right they're
investigating and then they say here's
what we're going to be indicted for and
then you need a trial and that so no
matter what it is that happens
it's not just up to those doing the
investigation to say ex person is guilty
of a crime it would be ex person we
believe committed this crime based on
this evidence
let's indict them and try them and
that's why there's only there's only one
path forward Anthony and that's voting
in November so that Democrats take over
the House and Senate that's it I wish I
wish there were more to it but that's it
do you think that molar is holding off
on ending the investigation until after
the 2018 elections I have no reason to
think that much that Robert Muller is
making political considerations when it
comes to the timing overall I think the
timing decisions he's making are what's
the order of who he interviews what's
the order of the indictments that he
announces on the basis of who does he
think might flip and assist and
cooperate with future parts right now I
don't I have no reason to think that he
is deliberately slow playing this to see
if Democrats take over the House and
Senate but it wouldn't be a crazy thing
to consider if you were Robert Moeller
for sure if you want to make sure that
your workers are not going to end up
being being thrown in the trash can
effectively Anthony thank you for the
call really appreciate it thank you all
right